planning a trip to Azeroth this winter
you should recent events have caused a
dollar as a Ratheon gold exchange rate
to skyrocket
booked now here are four helpful tips
that will make your visit easy and
painless
while property is always a risky
investment location location location
still apply just be sure to visit any
property you intend to buy when
determining what to pack check local
weather conditions make sure your gear
is appropriate for the places you plan
to visit remember the troll Scout motto
be prepared if you're planning a hunting
trip don't get trigger-happy check your
target we don't want any Dick Cheney
incidents that wolf just may be again
laying wah-wah consider an underwater
vacation new technology and shall we say
world altering events have unlocked the
depths of the ocean dreamed of visiting
a shipwreck wondered if goblin mermaids
exist want to see a half-eaten whale
carcass well now's your chance you can
do it all but only in a sarong vacation
packages are available December 7th book
book now they're filling up fast
[Music]